le mouvement de la négritude à ses
proches en fait de l'humanisme nous
avions rencontré en janvier au plus fort
de la grève contre la réforme des
retraites
six lycéens angoissé d'être privés de
classe il autant se serrer les coudes
trois mois plus tard c'est pour des
raisons bien différentes qui sont encore
loin du lycée
mes autres camarades l'entr'aide est
toujours là disons tu as tu es
entraîneur tu sais faire des
commentaires parfait mais le jour du bac
c'est malheureux tu tombes sur un texte
et inspire pas confiance
t'as pas envie a battu pourra toujours
aller sur la dissertation en fait
ruben et judith évoque les techniques de
commentaire de texte et de dissertation
pendant le confinement
les lycéens ont suivi les cours
dispensés par leurs professeurs par
écran interposé leurs devoirs ont été
corrigés et aujourd'hui le retour en
classe on mais suscite la plus forte
impatience mais aussi des interrogations
pour communiquer je rêve vraiment de
pouvoir retourner un jour en cour mais
le problème c'est que si on fait indique
confinement progressif va falloir quand
même une gare dit les gestes barrières
et pour ça ben déjà sans doute qu'on va
devoir être en demi groupe parce que
dans une classe entière dans une petite
salle ça ne ne peut pas à garder la
distance de sécurité en c'est totalement
impossible pendant le confinement
certains camarades de classe ont
malheureusement totalement décrochés
alors cette mameri ou craint beaucoup je
dit ça va ça se passe bien
allez ce matin
c'est bon il a contact avec tous les
profs ils ont des groupes whatsapp ils
ont des cours voilà je regarde des fois
je vois qu'il ya quand même pas mal
d'enfants en ligne donc je trouve cause
quand même même si non ils vont pas
forcément peut-être avoir tout ce qu'ils
auraient eu en temps normal mais je
crois que tout le monde fait en sorte
que ce soit optimale ruben et ses amis
n'ont qu'une hâte se retrouver reprendre
leurs études et le cours de leur vie
mais pour les familles sortir du
confinement veut dire s'exposer
davantage et pour certains les risques
sont plus grands
j'ai peur je n'ai clairement j'ai peur
par rapport à ma santé à moins on sait
que les enfants sont souvent porteurs ça
mais moi avec mes petits soucis de santé
et aussi fait que j mon père quand même
qu'à 82 ans je prépare aux prises en
temps un risque pour lui et voilà donc
c'est difficile
rubel lui est prêt à affronter les
contrôles puis l'oral de français prêts
aussi à prendre toutes les précautions
pour préserver sa famille est ce le
temps qu'il faudra